often it takes
england to play in a major tournament
for us to explore
englishness sparking a debate about what
it is to be
english now the archbishop of york is
calling on the country to protect
englishness
writing in the telegraph the most
reverend stephen cottrell said
many english people feel left behind by
metropolitan elites in london and the
south
east and by devolved governments and
strengthened regional identities in
scotland and wales
what we need is an expansive vision of
what it means to be
english as part of the uk a first
foundation would be a more developed and
strengthened regional government
within england we ask people in york
what they think of the idea of a
regional government
i think it would be a great idea to get
more voices heard
i wouldn't have westminster where it is
i'd have it in the middle of the country
i think it's a nonsense
i think certainly moving more of the
governance of the country
around the country i think will help the
archbishop didn't specify examples of
the metropolitan elite
but some academics say the country's
governance is the problem
we have very much in the state in
whitehall and the culture in westminster
and i don't just mean the conservatives
i mean the labour party as well
which tends to suppress any idea of
english nurse and say let's just talk
about britishness
but that's actually not where most
people in england are most people are
both british and they're english but
that english bit of themselves
is very important you're not allowed to
say that you are black and
english now that was a deliberate
decision by government and the office of
national
statistics so in wales you could say
that you're bangladeshi welsh
but in england you're not allowed to say
you're bangladeshi english
so is the church having to step in where
the government has failed to unite the
country
i think there's a crisis of englishness
actually and i think english identity
is a cause of embarrassment to one set
of people
and it's being into the vacuum the far
right is stepping in another direction
i think actually the church helping to
start a whole new national dialogue
about what it means to be english is a
really interesting development i love
those adjectives he uses courageous and
compassionate
i think i want to add one more which
would be diverse because i think
a multicultural nation is now becoming
integral to englishness as we've seen
recently from the uh
from the euros and from the english
football team and for our olympics team
as well
increasingly churches across the north
of england are having to step
in to meet human needs on issues of
poverty and destitution
the church of england says it's
investing in parts of the country which
are left behind
to be not just a church of england but
for england too
sadia chowdhury sky news